so now that we're all experts in OS two
point oh we know that the first thing we
want to do to assign the user in is
create a client ID so let's start doing
that now if you've created any client
IDs before for any other Google services
in the past you know that thing to do is
you go to code google com / AP I /
console and you know you create a new
project here call it screencast example
because I'm really creative and maybe we
turn on some services like the calendar
API and we'll accept terms of service
and then we go to the API access section
and we create knoweth to client ID we'd
add a product name my calendar project
and we might create one for a web
application where we would create a
client ID to find a redirect URI or
maybe an installed application where you
could set up something for an iOS device
like this and look at that we got a
client ID and everything is good right
wrong this is not the way you would set
up a client ID using the games API so if
you've been following along with the
last minute of what I've been doing stop
and erase everything you just did in
fact I'm going to go ahead and delete
this project yes I want to delete all
right so let's close this window here
and start again the reason I'm not
asking you to go to that Google API
console is that when you create a game
in game services you're enabling a bunch
of features such as leaderboards and
achievements and those need to be those
need to be set up and associated with a
client ID and so we're going to create
rof 2 point 0 client ID through the
Google Play Developer console instead so
let's look at that to get to the Google
Play Developer console you're going to
go to play google com / apps / publish
we get there you should
see a screen that maybe looks a little
something like this if you have never
used the Google Play Developer console
before you'll be prompted to create an
account which is something you are going
to have to do you do have to pay a
one-time fee of twenty-five dollars and
that's too I guess skied out the
spammers and no there's no way around it
even if you're just testing so if that's
you go ahead and pause this video create
an account and I'll see you back here in
a couple minutes okay now that we all
have account setup on the Google Play
Developer console the thing we're going
to do is click on this use Google Play
game services button this takes us to
the tab here on the left with this
little controller icon and we're going
to click on this button to set up Play
game services on a new game so because
this is a brand new project we're going
to say we don't use any Google API is in
our game yet this other tab I already
use google api is in my game would be
useful if say you had created api's in
the past on the Google API console that
I showed you earlier maybe you added
maps to your game or something and this
would successfully import that project
and associate that client ID with
whatever leaderboards and achievements
you create in the future in our case
it's much simpler we don't have any
google api is in our game yet and so
we're just going to create one from
scratch so the name of our game i'm
going to call guess my number and we'll
give it a category i think this is
really brain and puzzle you'll notice
this fine print underneath says hey
we're going to turn on cloud save
Google+ Google Play game services for
you all those switches on the google
api's console we don't need to do that
so we'll just click continue and let it
do its thing and now we're left with our
game details page this name and
description will inform how your game
appears throughout our system including
on the play games app that is available
on android devices so make this somewhat
user friendly maybe you could use your
Play Store description here as well in
our case we're just going to make
something you know actually we can just
leave this blank because we don't really
care for testing purposes
the high-rez icon the feature graphics
again this is what would appear
throughout our system including the play
games destination app so you'll want to
make sure that you use a nice icon and
graphic here again for testing purposes
we don't need any of this so I'm just
going to click Save and leave this blank
the next thing we're going to want to do
is create a linked application this
panel here is where we create our oaths
to point o client IDs as well as
associate them or I guess link them with
any achievements and leaderboards that
we create in the future because we are
creating an iOS app we're going to click
this link an iOS app button and we've
got the name of our app we're going to
say yes to iPhone and iPad hair even
though our game is really only optimized
for the iPhone you really only set this
to know if you didn't want users playing
this particular game on a particular
device in our case I'm happy to have
users playing games on my iPad as well
so I'm going to add our bundle
identifier which would be calm Google
guess my number and I'm going to leave
the itunes app ID blank for now hit save
and continue and we're going to get a
button saying click this to authorize
your app now so I'm going to click that
button and this is branding information
you might ask yourself hey wait a minute
i just added branding information what
is this stuff this is basically the name
and the logo that would appear in that
oath to point o dialog that pops up when
the user first signs into your
application so you want to make sure it
looks legitimate you want to make sure
your product name says something real
for a product logo well i'm going to
enter in a fantastic google logo in your
case you probably want to add something
associated with your own product or
company and our homepage URL will do
google com on this section you'll notice
your choices are very limited it's an
installed application and its iOS
confirm that this bundle ID is correct
it should be and if you have an app
store ID you can add it right here in
our case we can leave it blank and we
can hit create client
and look at that we now have a client ID
so now if you remember back to our
presentation remember how we said that
google keeps a database of client IDs
and authorize redirects well for our
guests my number game we now have a
client ID which we just got back from
the Google Play Developer console as
well as an authorized redirect which is
based on the bundle identifier that we
gave to the system so this column google
gets my number colon slash a lot to call
back that is now associated with our
application and you'll see how we use
that very shortly so there we go we now
have a client ID keep a note of this
maybe copy and paste it into a text file
somewhere because you're going to need
this however if you forget to and you
need it again at some point in your
linked apps listings if you just click
on this you'll see it right here so you
can always get to your client ID if you
ever need it by the way let's look at
our other panels here you'll see
achievements this is where we'll be able
to set up achievements at some point in
the future leaderboards where we'll be
able to set up leaderboards and testing
which is where we can add test accounts
that are allowed to access these game
services before we publish definitely go
to the testing panel if you haven't and
confirm that the account that you're
planning on testing with is added here
by default it should add the account
that you're using to develop with along
with any other accounts on your team
unless they don't have a G+ account set
up in which case they won't get added
but again you might be using a different
account to test with than the one you're
developing with and if that is the case
click this add testers button and you
can add for example you know example at
gmail com that's probably not a real
address we won't actually add this but
if you did add some addresses they would
be listed here as well by the way you
might also notice that we've got some
green icons next Easter each of our
sections and they signify different
things if an icon is a half green circle
like this that basically means that
you've provided enough information to
start testing the game but not enough to
have published the game if you provide
enough information to publish this
particular section it will have a green
check like this and if the
is really a problem you'll see this grey
triangle icon so we can see here that
everything is set up enough for us to at
least test however we're not allowed to
publish yet and if you click on this
section you'll see that it gives you a
number of things that are missing so we
don't have an icon for game details we
don't have an itunes app ID and we need
to provide at least five achievements
for a game so we're good enough for
testing not enough for publishing but
that's okay because really testing is
all we need for development purposes so
now that we've gotten our very first
client ID let's make use of it and
really add that sign-in button and we're
going to do that in the next lesson
bah bah bah bah
proper